[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans kiosque votre
émission culturelle nous démarrons tout
de suite avec le sommaire de l'émission
Christian Janot expose ses plissements
jusqu'au demain la médiathèque saint
exupéré de voisin le Bretonneux le
photographe nous parlera de son travail
si particulier claire de la varen est
une spécialiste de l'histoire de l'art
le 5 mai animera une conférence sur
véasquez alors que le peintre espagnol
est à l'honneur en ce moment au Grand
Palais à Paris songe d'une nuit d'été de
Shakespeare revue et corrigé par la
compagnie d'improvisation Déclic Théâtre
c'est également à découvrir dans le
kiosque avec Nicolas Gervet qui a
rencontré Mélanie le mooine mais avant
tout cela je vous propose d'ouvrir une
page
exposition
il expose jusqu'au de ma la médiathèque
saintexupéri de voisin le brotonneux et
puis à partir du 5 mai au Centre Alfred
dein toujours à voisin le Bretonneux
c'est Christian Janot vous êtes
photographe bonsoir merci d'être à
l'invité de de kiosque tout d'abord
votre exposition qui se déroule en ce
moment la médiiaatek saintupéri
s'appelle plissement pourquoi plissement
c'est quoi ces plissements ces
plissements sont des plissements
métalliques des plissement de tissu
déplissement de plastique ce qui a même
de peinture ce qui a
qui m'a permis de voir certaines choses
et à partir de là j'ai cultivé toute ce
ce domaine pour arriver à un thème qui
soit cohérent et on voit que ça donne
envie de faire de la grandeur dans cette
exposition et non pas du microscopique
microscopique vous allez nous parler de
ce que vous arrivez à voir parce que
c'est c'est là l'essence même de votre
travail mais pourquoi l'intérêt pour ces
plissement qui vous plaît le côté vague
ondulé je sais pas moi-même quand je les
vois mon premier ma première impression
c'est ça peut être beau puisque quand
vous voyez à l'exposition cette vague
qui donne une impression de de monter
vers le ciel ces oiseaux qui font penser
à hhcock bon ça crée à l'intérieur de la
personne qui regarde du moins j'espère
une une évasion donc ça veut dire que
quand on est photographe il avir de
l'imagination je pense que oui puisque
par la prise de vue quelque chose qui
pourrait être vraiment frontal et à plat
là on voit que si on prend Leon bon
angle très rapidement parce que des fois
on n pas toujours beaucoup de temps on
arrive à un bon résultat et j'espère que
par exemple là je vois ce nœud ce nœud
pour moi c'était une une
union de deux êtres bon dans les poésies
qui ont été rendues certains ont vu cela
et un jeunne a vu une sal effectivement
vous expliquerez ça après parce que les
gens pouvaient effectivement pendant
l'exposition déposer des textes 80
textes qui ont été déposés et là on a vu
on n expliquerit que que certains ont
fait preuve de beaucoup d'imagination je
voudrais revenir sur votre façon de
travailler étrangement quand on voit vos
photos on se dit c'est des photos prises
avec un appareil photo bah pas du tout
non c'est effectivement un mobile bien
téléphone portable tout simple
exactement grâce à mes collègues qui
m'ont aidé à évoluer puisque au début je
considérais que c'était suffisant et
m'ont invité à prendre le modèle qui
avait un peu un peu un peu au-dessus
mais euh pourquoi le téléphone portable
parce que c'est quoi c'est l'instantané
c'est on l'a dans la poche on sort on
voit quelque chose c'est tellement
pratique effectivement puisque quand on
prend même si je ne prends pas de
personne ni de de de d'animaux j'ai la
facilité quand je suis dans le métro
dans la rue de voir quelque chose et
tout de suite même si par exemple le
métro arrive euh j'ai eu le temps de me
cadrer et de trouver la bonne
orientation voilà c'est la
rapidité avec un minimum
de d'effort on va
dire par rapport à l'événement alors
quand on voit V vos photos qui sont
effectivement très très belles très
imaginatives on se dit elles sont
peut-être retouchées mais non pas du
tout c'est un vrai partiprix de pas les
retoucher aujourd'hui on ne sait plus
qui est quoi et on sait plus la vérité
voilà donc le but c'est effectivement là
j'ai par exemple une coulée qui
représente un un tigre et ce tigre a un
Méo dans la bouche dans la gueule on
pourrait se dire ça serait peut-être
mieux de retoucher d'enlever ce MIGO
mais à ce moment-là pour moi j'enlève le
contexte et en même temps ce contexte je
vous allez également le chercher puisque
j'ai essayé de le D délocaliser et c'est
aussi un but de mes photos c'està
direire que la personne devant une photo
va se poser la question où a-t-elle été
prise
quelle est la matière et c'est là où on
retrouve la recherche de matière de du
buffet donc là c'est vraiment la vérité
à l'état pur la photo vous l'avez
pratiqué tout jeune puis après vous avez
arrêté puis vous êtes revenu à la
photographie c'était il y a il y a à peu
près 4 ans vous m'avez raconté ça en
préparant cette émission c'était en
revenant d'un voyage au Népal vous avez
fait une photo et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé quand on vous avait regardé cette
photo j'ai vu dans un escalier puisque
quand on va au Népal bon etélas
aujourd'hui on est un petit peu triste
hein de ce qui se passe euh je me suis
aperçu que dans un des escaliers se
trouvait une tête que je n'avais pas vu
en prenant la photo et je me suis dit
que vous avez que vous avez découvert
après après et je me suis dit peut-être
que quand je me promène il y a plein de
choses comme ça que je ne vois pas ça
crée un stimuli et une recherche de de
ces de ces photos où on verrait soit un
mouvement soit un être soit un animal
mal euh voilà donc vous avez l'œil
aiguisé à chaque fois pour voir ce que
vous appelez vous la troisème vue hein
c'està direire ce que on voit pas au
départ mais qui est se cache derrière
alors beaucoup de gens connaissent le
principe des nuages quand on est jeune
on regarde les nuages on dit je vois euh
un chien je vois une tête de personne
bon ça ça a un nom ça s'appelle
l'apparé d' d'Oli euh qui traduit en
fait cette capacité euh avoir dans des
formes dans des oui dans dans des formes
quelque chose qui euh ressemble à la
réalité voilà donc donc vous avez le le
le trème œil alors on va dire ce trè œil
oui comme je dis à beaucoup de gens
c'est que je je suis parti de de
l'inconnu c'estàd je l'ai fait sans
savoir que euh bon il y avait d'autres
personnes qui avaient cette capacité et
en recherchant j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait
euh certaines une personne qui connu tel
que Aaron siskin qui dans sa deuxième
partie de vie après des reportages c'est
beaucoup beaucoup aller sur ce terrain
euh donc je l'ai dit l'exposition à la
médiathèque saint pér c'est jusqu'au 2
mai les visiteurs pouvaient laisser des
textes effectivement il y a eu 80 textes
qui ont été laissés qu'on peut retrouver
aussi sur votre site internet parce que
sur sur le site internet on peut
retrouver C ces textes là qu'est-ce qui
vous a étonné dans dans ce que les gens
ont laissé comme petit message comme
poème comme comme inspiration alors
certains sont très sérieux et d'autres
sont très ludiques et et c'est
cette par
exemple une photo représentait
un musicien on va dire puisque c'était
un papier laissé sur le sol que j'avais
vu et j'ai vu un trompettiste et une
personne a donné des mots une suite de
mots saccadés et en traitant sur le sur
le papier et ces mots sacadés donnent
presque l'impression de de rythme de
musique voilà
et du coup ça réinvente il vous voyez
peut-être les photos différemment donc
jusqu'au 2 mai à la médiathèque cupéri
pour ceux qui veulent découvrir vos
plissements et à partir du 5 mai vous
restez à boisin bronux vous serez au
centre Alfred de viin là vous serez
confronté à d'autres photographes et ça
sera sur un thème plus animal j'ai envie
de dire oui puisque le thème c'est qui a
été imposé c'était animal donc avec des
photographes qui font vraiment des
photos d'animaux donc pour contrer être
à la hauteur de l'exposition j'ai pensé
à créer un ensemble que j'ai appelé
aquarium donc aquarium ça sera découvrir
au central Fred de viin à partir de du 5
mai voilà et donc j'espère que les
personnes il verront
différentes différents éléments de
matière pour le même la même chose qui
est qui sont des poissons alors donc
l'éplissement c'est jusqu'au 2 mai à la
médiiathèque Saint exupéri et les
aquariums ou l'aquarium en tout cas le
thème de l'eau c'est à découvrir à
partir du 5 mai au Centre Alfred de vin
tout est un voisin le Bretonneux merci
beaucoup à chrisan Jano d'être venu sur
le plateau de kiosque merci à vous allez
on poursuit cette émission toujours
autour de la photographie des souvenirs
de famille de voyage de simples moments
pris sur le vif ou encore des créations
numériques ces clichés sont exposés en
ce moment à la mairie de guilloncour les
auteurs de ces photographies participent
au concours réflex organisé par ville
pour la 4e année consécutive yolen Torz
pour le
commentaire des souvenirs de famille de
voyage de simples moments pris sur le
vif ou encore des créations numériques
ces clichés sont exposés en ce moment à
la mairie de guyoncour les auteurs de
ces photographies participent au
concours réflex organisé par la ville
pour la 4e année consécutive réflex
permet aux amateurs d'exposer une à deux
photographies de pouvoir présenter leurs
travaux et également peut-être se faire
connaître et reconnaître dans le monde
de la photographie il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui viennent des ivlines la
majorité beaucoup de en courtois mais
également quelques personnes une
personne de Paris et une personne de
tour gratuit et ouvert à tous le
concours compte trois catégories la
photographie couleur la photographie
noir et blanc ainsi que la création
numérique aucun thème n'a été imposé
libre cours à l'imagination sur les 49
créations déposées 36 ont été retenus
pour
l'exposition
il y a C prix qui ont été remis quatre
prix ont été remis par le jury donc le
Prix du Jury bien évidemment le prix de
la photographie couleur le prix de la
photographie noire et blanc le prix de
la création numérique et un dernier prix
est attribué par le public par les
personnes qui visitent l'exposition
c'est le prix du public le public peut
voter jusqu'à 16h le jeudi 7 mai jour du
vernissage les gagnants se verront
remettre des bons d'achat et des
abonnements
magazine et on reste toujours à gui en
cours pour une autre exposition mais
cette fois à la salle d'exposition les
œuvres d'Anne slassique autour de
l'Opéra de stockousen licht la série des
sept œuvres sera présentée pour la
première fois deux ensembles seront
également présentés celui créé à partir
du texte en prose de Stéphane malarmé Le
nénufar blanc et celui créé à partir du
poème d'André duboucher l'avril c'est
donc à découvrir jusqu'à dimanche à la
salle d'exposition de guillancour et
puis une autre exposition cette fois
autour du paysage c'est à hlencour le
travail de Jean-François
qui souhaite transformer notre
perception du paysage et donc à
découvrir en ce moment à la Commanderie
des Templiers d'élancour l'entrée et
[Musique]
libre mardi prochain aura lieu la
dernière conférence de la saison pour le
conservatoire des arts de montig le
Bretonneux sur Vélasquez explication
avec Claire de laavaren une conférence
comme on voudrait en rencontrer plus
souvent Sephora Namani et
eloimoine à la manière d'Obélix claire
de la varen est tombé de d petite ce qui
l'anime et laa fait vivre c'est sa
passion pour l'art un parcours
artistique pluriel et diversifié a
conduit cet ancien élève de l'École du
Louvre à devenir peintre restauratrice
de tableau et conférencière en art lors
de ces conférences accompagnées de
projection claire ne cherche pas à nous
raconter l'histoire mais à nous donner à
voir je ne me contente pas de parler de
la biographie du peintre de
l'iconographie du tableau bien sûr je le
fais un minimum mais comme je peins je
vois la facture je vois le style un
tableau c'est pas seulement ce qui
représente ou l'histoire de la vie du
peintre c'est vraiment comment il est
peint son style sa facture les touches
de pinceau les rapports de couleurs
d'ombre et de lumière c'est tout ça qui
fait qu'un peintre a un style
particulier et pour faire comprendre au
mieux le style dans un tableau claire
prend toujours pour exemple la façon de
peindre les portraits de celui que l'on
surnomme le peintre des peintres
véasquez quand il peint comme ça un œil
le nez enfin une partie de visage il va
pas faire tous les poils des sourcils le
creux de la paupière il va peindre une
masse sombre qui va prendre dans l'ombre
aussi bien une partie de l'iris de la
paupière du sourcil et de l'ombre du nez
et dès qu'on se recule tout est là il y
a même la personnalité la force la la
psychologie du visage et ça c'est
épououflant lors de sa conférence claire
proposera parmi ses projections le
portrait du pape Innocent 10 de véasquez
exposé actuellement au Grand Palais non
sans malice un portrait considéré par
certains comme le plus beau portrait du
monde vous savez que ce tableau le le le
pape avait dit trop vero trop vrai et ce
qui est extraordinaire à l'exposition
c'est que ce panneau
d'90 ce tableau est sur un panneau et de
l'autre côté du panneau il y a une copie
on voit la copie et on comprend tout
c'est un tableau qui qui peut frapper
tout le monde à condition qu'on montre
aussi comment c'est peint parce que
sinon j'ai peur que des gens passent en
se
disant un PAP on s'en fiche quoi mais un
PAP peint par
véasque pour découvrir d'autres
anecdotes sur véasqueè et les subtilités
de sa facture
rendez-vous mardi 5 mai au conservatoire
des arts de
Montini le songe d'e nuit d'été de
Shakespeare revue est corrigé par la
compagnie d'improvisation déclic thé
toutes les explications avec Mélanie le
moine c'est tout de suite et c'est dans
la chronique de Nicolas Gervet nous
sommes à la merurise à trrappe et c'est
derrière cette porte qu'ils répète leur
dernière création qu'ils présenteront
ici même les C si après l'istrata en
2011 il s'attaque cette fois à
Shakespeare avec le Songe d'une nuit
d'été mais comme il s'agit de déclic
théâ c'est forcément un peu décalé comme
nous allons le voir tout de suite avec
Mélanie l moine
allons-y en
voil où es-tu
fierrius ici il point et je suis
prê j've tout de suite on a créérata
maintenant il y a 4 pres
et là on Satta à Shakespeare après
Aristophane d'abord parce que
Shakespeare c'est anglais donc c'est
forcément traduit donc c'est forcément
adapté de la même façon qu'on avait
adapté le texte de d'Aristophane on
s'est dit bah voilà si on prend un texte
anglais et ancien on a plus de liberté
on se sentait un peu plus libre pour
l'adaptation donc on a travaillé avec
une adaptation d'un monsieur qui
s'appelle Daniel LOA on a fait quelques
coupes on a changé quelques mots par-ci
par là voilà finalement moins que ce
qu'on pensait je pensais qu'on allait
beaucoup tordre le texte et et en fait
pas tant que ça nuit harassante que tes
heures sabèchent brille à l'Orient
lumière consolatrice afin que ta clarté
me reconduise vers athèn le songe du
nuudété ça parle de théâtre et encore
plus dans la l'interprétation qu'on a
faite Jean-Philippe salerio qui est mur
en scène ça ne parle quasiment que de
théâtre et je trouvais intéressant cette
perspective enfin cette mise en
perspective de dire bah voilà les
comédiens de la compagnie d'épis de
théâtre ils sont plutôt habitués des
matchs d'impro des spectacles d'impro et
ben ils vont découvrir le théâtre de la
même façon que dans la le spectacle il y
a des personnages qui découvrent le
théâtre plus qu'une donc et deux et deux
quatre ferous mais la voilà triste et
furieuse quel châtiment quel gardnement
ce Cupidon qui rend lâche ces
malheureux c'est une comédie déjà donc
c'est quand même déjà comme Aristophane
enfin comme le texte de lis stratal
était le texte du songe est déjà drôle
c'est déjà une comédie c'est déjà des
des mondes qui se croisent qui
s'entrechoquent il y a ces fées qui sont
là puis il y a ces petits jeunes qui
sont amoureux puis qui fuiti dans la
forêt puis il y a ces artisans qui
montent un spectacle pour le duc puis il
y a ce duc et tous ces personnages se
croisent donc déjà bien sûr que c'est
décalé parce que c'est un une
confrontation enfin c'est des
confrontations de monde qui ont rien à
voir donc oui c'est c'est sûr que c'est
décalé mais c'est Shakespeare qui a
voulu décaler c'est pas des clics
d'après tout ce que j'ai pu lire ou pu
entendre dans les contes ou dans
l'histoire le cours de l'amour vrai
n'aura jamais été paisible qu'elle
croit écoute Herm j'ai une tente veuve
une doerrière qui a de grands bien mais
aucun enfant dont la maison se trouve à
Sep lieux d'Athène elle me considère
comme son fils unique là-bas du seria je
pourrais t'épouser une des raisons de
cette pièce c'est aussi que c'est une
pièce avec beaucoup de personnages et
que moi j'avais envie vraiment après le
fiestacle on avait vu voilà toute cette
matière vive qui existe à des clics tous
ces comédiens qui sont jeunes qui ont
envie qui sont à l'aisees sur des
plateau qui ont une énergie de dingue
j'avais envie qu'on qu'on fasse quelque
chose avec beaucoup de monde et que ça
respire cette force là de la jeunesse
qui qui a envie une des particularités
du spectacle c'est que ça mélange des
jeunes comédiens des très jeunes
comédiens qui sont pas encore
professionnels qui sont peut-être qui
seront peut-être jamais professionnel
mais en tout cas qui sont des jeunes
comédiens de chez nous donc ont quand
même pas mal d'expérience de la scène et
puis des comédiens plus âgés et qui ont
eux une solide expérience du classique
du théâtre voilà donc on mêle tous ces
tous ces gens-là on est 13 sur le
plateau avec le avec un musicien dors
comme un bien
heureux pendant que je déverse dans
chacun dans le texte d'origine il y a
des moments chantés donc on a demandé à
Nicolas Duclou qui avait déjà fait la
musique pour lesistrata d'écrire de la
musique et des chansons sur les moments
qui étaient censés être chantés il y a
cette présence très très forte du
théâtre un peu baroque avec une toile
peinte avec des des des costumes assez
guindés assez élisabéthtin avec du bois
des des matières assez assez
traditionnelles on va dire euh et puis à
côté des couleurs un peu plus vives pour
les pour les jeunes amoureux euh ou pour
les artisans lui ne veut pas savoir ce
que tous savent sauf
lui car avant que des mérius et vu le
regard d'Hermia c'estes serments dru
comme greve certifié qu'il était à
moi et après chpire on retrouve cat rine
chat 4at c'est nul ouais c'est vrai
mais non c'est pas nul allez l'oubli des
anges maintenant un opéra danse
contemporain qui aborde le moment de la
dernière séparation aujourd'hui encore
la mort danse chante mais en tout cas ne
se dit pas un spectacle de la compagnie
interface est à voir mardi 5 mai à la
salle jacbrel de montig à 20h30 tarif à
partir de 16,70 € on en regarde un
[Musique]
extrait
et une maintenant musique à retenir
concert événement
natbrahou la de la batterie de gu sera
6i Atlas Victoire de la Musique en 2000
revient avec un album qu'elle signe donc
avec le compositeur Ibrahim malouf deux
artistes réunis autour de la culture
orientale avec des accents de jazz un
concert rare à découvrir mercredi 6 mai
à 20h30 tarif à partir de 16,50 € et je
vous propose notamment justement pardon
d'écouter la voix de Natacha Atlas une
voix
[Musique]
envûante
you St the things you
[Musique]
do I
can't
r
[Musique]
can't
voilà tout l'univers de Natacha Atlas à
découvrir donc mercredi SIM la batterie
de Guillon court et pour terminer nos
idées de sortie le festival bouillon
club à ne pas club pardon à ne pas
confondre avec un aliment c'est plutôt
le festival qui donne du goût à la
culture spectacle de hip hop danse
oriental concert de jazz escrime aussi
atelier de sculpture Aikido peinture un
savoureux mélange à découvrir donc ce
samedi de 10h à 21h sur le terreplein
situé à l'entrée de l'avenue de
Versailles à Versailles l'entrée est
libre
allez comme tous les mercredis à la
chronique cinéphil et en cette période
de vacance qu'est-ce que vous allez voir
au cinéma réponse avec Mathide capverne
c'est un film original parce que ça se
base sur une caméra caché et puis
l'actrice est très bonne voilà donc
c'est un film tout à fait divertissant
et sur une idée originale nul c'est
vulgaire c'est c'est ça fait même pas
rire
c'est voilà c'est ennuyant c'est tout ce
que vous voulez voilà c'est c'est bien
dommage pour le cinéma français c'est
une une tête à claque quoi on a
envie de la claqué tout le long du film
c'est bien joué voilà sympa très bien
dialogue bon dialogue c'est c'est c'est
marrant on a passé un excellent moment
c'est tous beaucoup amusé une très très
belle interprétation très belle mise en
scène non non on le conseille voilà les
conseils des des spectateurs et
maintenant le coup de cœur d'un
professionnel du Samar ce soir Luc
beauquan du cé 7 d'élancour
cette semaine au ciné un film français
un film américain comme ça la la parité
est respectée si je puis dire je vais
commencer par le film français donc en
équilibre de de mercour avec Albert
Dupontel et Cécile de France donc un
très beau film qui raconte l'histoire
d'un d'un cavalier qui se blesse
gravement et qui devient donc handicapé
qui va rencontrer un agent d'assurance
ils vont se lier tous les deux il va
continuer à faire du cheval c'est un
mélodrame qui est bien équilibré bien
réalisé très bien interprété donc il
avoir sur V écrans cette semaine et le
deuxième film c'est sty Alice qui
fonctionne pas très bien on comprend pas
pourquoi dans les salles de cinéma qui a
valu un Oscar à Julian moour qui est une
actrice américaine comment dirais-je
très très très bonne actrice américaine
et là ça raconte l'histoire d'une femme
qui va découvrir petit à petit au fur à
mesure qu'elle commence à perdre la la
mémoire et qu'elle est donc frappée par
la maladie d'Alzheimer donc c'est un
drame aussi très prenant très bien fichu
avoir dans cette semaine c'est peut-être
la dernière année que je serai moi-même
tu sais s'il te plaît ne dis pas
ça cette émission mant terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez-vous mercredi
prochain d'ici là excellente fin de
[Musique]
semaine y